foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ly shading her ex Gerard PK and their
high profile split it's been quite a
journey over the weekend the Colombian
singer accepted the woman of the year
honor at Billboard's first Latin women
in music Gala
[Applause]
during her acceptance speech Shakira
opened up about personal struggles from
the past year
yeah
the Grammy winner seems to also
reference her breakup with Gerard
including the cheating allegations
surrounding him okay
pasado
for example
[Applause]
purpose
and One Thing Shakira says got her
through it all her music
[Music]
the unspeculated Shakira's first single
Of The Year bizarrep music sessions
volume 53 through Digs at Gerard and his
relationship with girlfriend Clara
chiamarti
[Music]
then there's Shakira's newest track
tequedo Grande with Carol g a song about
bravely moving on after a breakup
[Music]
foreign
she was like you know what with this one
it's about my process then this one is
that moment when you just let everything
go and and this is my way to express
myself that relationship with oneself in
which so many so many things come to
play you know especially being committed
to your own goals in life and not giving
up and not abandoning or throwing in the
towel too soon just because the
environment tries to bring you down
Shakira mentioned in her billboard
speech the most important lesson she's
learned are from other women writing and
singing the songs for them adding quote
because only a woman can love until
she's ripped apart
is
[Applause]
foreign